I'm dr. fleet Max Rouge I work for the
Bermuda government overseeing the
shipwrecks that surround this island
every one of them has an incredible
story to tell now I've been the
custodian of historic wrecks for the
islands of Bermuda for about just over a
decade now there are over 300 shipwrecks
around this island which is actually
quite incredible because it's not that
big a place which means that pretty much
anywhere you swim you're gonna bump into
a shipwreck they form an integral part
of our national identity it's one of the
Bermudas most iconic shipwrecks there's
actually two shipwrecks laid on top of
each other you have the constellation
that came afterwards in the Montana the
debris from the constellation is washed
right through the center of this
shipwreck so you have a very confounding
set of artifacts you have some from the
20th century and some from the 19th
century everything's that are rolled
into one it's a really historically
relevant shipwreck it was part of the
fleet of these blockade runners that ran
very quickly to feed the Confederate
South with weapons during the Civil War
this was an iron ship she had large
paddle wheels on either side and big
engines in the center and so a lot of
that is still completely intact you can
still go into parts and the shipwrecks
and have a look around but the bow just
completely occluded by hard coral the
stern is nestled down between reefs that
have clearly grown up around it because
it's pretty shallow and because it's
pretty rocky you can imagine those hard
corals would have settled on it pretty
quickly this is how nature wants to be
on this shipwreck you know there's been
no interference that's actually one of
the things we're trying to accomplish is
in monitoring these shipwrecks we can
actually measure to some extent how fast
coral grows and you know with a changing
environment with our concerns about
climate change how coral responds and
how coral grows is a pretty important
thing and so these shipwrecks also a
really great opportunity for us to
establish a start point and decide from
there how long it has it has it taken
for sensing nature to take it over
these unfortunate human events actually
art simply absorbed by nature and turned
into another one of its beautiful
phenomena these shipwrecks are sort of
part of historical narrative to tell us
but they also have important to science
function as they operate is kind of like
a you know a benchmark if you want in
the environment so for how things have
changed up until now and how they're
going to change going forward and
because they hold our interest they're
also a really important segue to getting
people to care about the marine
environment
you